and I go to the the Marine office I'm
like hello anybody in here
and then this guy like crawls up from
underneath the desk are you here to join
the Marines
dude this is my place
[Music]
I thought this would be a really
interesting question to answer
uh since we're off the Record currently
off of the record
um and it would be an interesting answer
for BART to hear from all of us
the question is
why didn't you join the military
oh Jesus why why why would it why would
be interesting because you actually did
did you ever have a dream because I have
a big fat [__] mouth that's why I I
don't think I could handle somebody
telling me what to do you're from a
military family exactly wait are all
your siblings military your sister well
my sister's not but she is hot she was
too hot to join she would have served
them too good too hot to join yeah yeah
they wouldn't let her how many bows you
got I got two brothers and an older
sister but all your but all your uh
relatives are military every single one
and the reason like they never pressured
you to join never no do they all sit
around and make fun of you like you're
like the non-military nah they know not
to because I'll hit them back 10 times
harder
they're like you're just I'll go and
I'll go personal do you think that's
what made you funny uh because he was a
non-military one the non-military guy I
think it was more just like attention
right because like you're I'm in a big
family like four kids you have to like
fight for every like bit of moment in
the sun you're like it's like those
plants at the jungle floor like you
gotta really work to like get to the
light uh I think that was when did you
have the for sure I'm not gonna do it
was it like in high school earlier or
like I remember making my girlfriend at
the time cry because I was like I'm
probably gonna get out of the military I
don't [__] know because like I cried
yeah she was like crying about because
because this was like around Afghanistan
but I was [__] pissed I was like I'm
gonna go kill some talibans yeah
yeah and I was but I was calling them
worse things than that racial epithets
yeah
no uh but I was I remember just thinking
like I'm probably gonna have to join
because of all the things going on like
with Iraq and stuff like that but then
um as it got closer and closer to the
reality of that
like I was like yeah I don't know that I
could actually do it like I'm not I
could actually
like be good at it because I'm really
bad at respecting anybody telling me
yeah I'm really bad at it I knew about
um Al Qaeda before mainstream America
knew about Al Qaeda yeah I had a book
and then the crazy thing is these two
Taliban has start taking each other's
robes off and they're sucking each other
I was watching this video about it
somebody has to stop these guys I was in
about
I was like 8th or ninth grade eighth or
ninth grade right I had a book called
21st century uh terrorism because in
junior high I just had this like okay I
think in elementary school right
probably most people's first like
introduction to being a soldier or
whatever was GI Joe
I think GI Joe was part of the cartoon
first like Real American Hero exposure
to like
Soldier Romanticism like I want to
[__] be in the Army that's what boys
do that's what men do right and then you
have the little green army men that you
would play with your friends and stuff
and then you get like the machine guns
and you have water fights and then
you're just like Good Guys bad guys
right and then you obsess about this
stuff and you like think one day I'ma be
a [__] Soldier and you get like camel
fatigues you dress like a soldier during
Halloween and then like I believe that I
was gonna be somewhat military and then
I started picking up books magazine and
I was like wow like I learned about a
soldier of fortune and mercenary groups
that you can like get military training
outside of just joining the military
fast forward to like reading about uh
21st century terrorism
they were talking about how like
U.S P like people that want to be
private contractors they can go to
Taliban camps and get training outside
of the US because then if you're like
secret secret then you can basically
like
learn all these like skills without
being a part of the military program in
the U.S and I was like that's [__]
crazy and then when I deep dived into
everything I was like
everything is kind of the same like
countries all just have soldiers that do
what the country wants them to do so
then there's no good guy bad guy
everyone's just power like hungry and
then at that point I was like [__]
well does that mean my country is a good
country
but is it really good though and then
that's like because in high school you
just start reading all these things
about like wait the CIA was selling
drugs to like
the black community and using that money
to buy soldiers in Costa Rica or
whatever and I'm like what the [__] is
all this stuff and I think that was
scaring me to the point where I'm like
who do I trust and if I join the
military does that mean that I'm gonna
be used or I don't know and that scared
the [__] out of me like at that point I
was like why even be a part of society
if everything is a lie versus just
talking to a recruiter
well how would the recruiter know
everyone's brainwashed at that point I
know but it's just crazy that like you
you did all your own research you went
to the library for for 40 months yeah
the guy outside the school like anyone
wants to join do some pull-ups do some
pull-ups yeah yeah
you get a ten thousand dollar check it
was it was like six six to tenth grade
so sixth to tenth grade I think like
that was just all of that yeah and there
were guys that would walk around and
doing the junior was it the ROTC [__]
yeah yeah the junior military guys
and then I was like that's so cool but
yeah I didn't even go that route because
at that point I I think also that's when
I was also leaving religion so
everything that was like um your words
were like crumbly everything was scary
because everything was like that's fake
this is fake this is fake yeah
so that's kind of like I think what
people are going through with the woke
[__] but like they're just adults but I
went through that like in ninth grade
damn dude I just didn't want people to
tell me what to do
Anthony why didn't you enlist
uh I like Steve I think um during that
time especially coming from being an
eagle scout a lot of guys well yeah they
joined the military yeah I feel like
right when 9 11
um
maybe happened
yeah we got you yeah
we saw the video
yeah during that time uh when 9 11
happened I I definitely remember that
that was the most uh patriotic that I
felt but at the same time I was only 16.
and then by the time I was like nearly
18 uh you know I we maybe were looking
at things like I was definitely looking
at things like JROTC and ROTC and stuff
to kind of like look into it because it
was close to things that I was familiar
with but
I maybe just didn't have enough of uh a
realistic urge to like go that far when
I had
um I think confusion as a senior in high
school not knowing what my purpose or
career would be I strongly entertained
it as well when I just didn't I don't
know if it was like patriotism or just
lack of understanding of what I would do
yeah you know what I mean when you're
just like I don't know what I'm gonna do
with my life so then you're like oh
well if I go to this then they're going
to give me this and this and this or
I'll definitely be able to get this
super good option yeah I'm pretty sure
I'm like not going to be a loser there
because like I'm very familiar with how
to do certain things so it was like
practical so I definitely considered it
I definitely went to a a recruitment
place or recruiter and I like had some
conversations but just never end up
crossing the line my sister was like
this close to actually joining because
it was going to pay for her vet school
but then my grandparents ended up
co-signing and then also my sister when
she was there with the recruiter they
said that her titties were too big to
fit me oh
that's crazy I was I was a recruiter for
a period of time yeah they tried they
had to try it on yeah
we try another size my uncle's the
buttons ricocheting and damaged Soldier
they got medical leave though five
thousand dollars a month for the rest of
his life yeah
it was a if she doesn't need a
bulletproof vest yeah that [__] bounces
it back
my uncle saw um Pearl Harbor go down
when he was a kid was he in the planes
attacking them
what was the view
oh is it like that
here we go dude it was right there the
guy saw it he was like he said after
school so so they they would all work on
this Watercress Farm in Hawaii so after
school they're like picking [__]
whatever doing some peasant ass [__]
right and then he just saw the planes
like crashing down and he was like what
the [__] and then um you know military
is one of the ways where like broke kids
could see the world so he's like I want
to travel so then he goes you know you
meet so many people that are on base in
Hawaii that come from all over and he's
like oh yeah I want to go visit
different places so that's like one of
the reasons why and I was thinking yeah
I think the military though like the way
I went into it was so cynical and like
the mentality of like wow this is such a
scary thing that people can use you for
and thing but I still think it's a good
thing for poor working class or even
people that are in broken homes to like
get into a system that can help you
discipline yourself and build character
because it's
designed to get like a straight up
jungle man with no education into
becoming a part of an organized group so
I was like at the end of the day it's up
to you what you do after boot camp and I
mean leaving the program it's like yeah
would you say like the military it's for
jungle man
no the military making jungle men into
civilized men oh okay okay
it's for jungle man is that why uh you
didn't want to do it well I think that's
a two jungle men didn't want to become a
civilized man no at the time I think um
the sentiment of the military in the
Middle East was like not good like by
public opinion everybody was like oh
they're they're like killing people
they're like you know by that time we've
never found the weapons of mass
destruction yet
we bombed like three countries that's
true because by the time we we were like
we saw 911 and everyone was like I'm
joining yeah by the time it was next
Generation it was like wait what are we
doing there yeah it was like let's pull
out we're still looking for if you read
the David K report don't worry the
government investigated themselves they
found that Iraq was in possession of
some things they shouldn't have had it
too though don't worry about it oil
y'all checked out long-range missiles
for example so like I think that was a
sentiment at the time and then I
remember
a lot of it was like anecdotal too it
was like some of my sister's friends had
joined the military and they would come
back and they would tell stories about
like their time overseas in Iraq and it
was just like pretty rough stories or
just
who knows how true they were at the time
because this guy was a little kind of
crazy the guy that was like telling us
these stories in retrospect like years
looking back but he just was like yeah
he just had a lot of bad things to say
about like the military oh I wouldn't do
it again blah blah blah so at the time
but recruiter yeah but I think but I
wasn't necessarily like really ever into
thinking about joining the military
because I think growing up my uncles and
like my dad would always be like yeah
it's [__] a load of [__] you know
like oh really they're kind of like
they're kind of like that like don't
even waste your time they're just gonna
use you they just want you to [__]
fight other people's Wars like that's
how they would talk about it in the
military so Me growing up I just was
like well I'm just not gonna do that
like I didn't really have an interest in
it I didn't really I was kind of neutral
about it either way but I never had a
feeling of like I'm gonna join the
military but in retrospect a couple
years later I think it probably would
have been a good thing for me if I
joined the military like honestly like
in going through that boot camp I think
it would have gave me a lot of structure
but you know do you think you wouldn't
have been 15 minutes late today if you
join them I think my bed would have been
made I think my boots would have been
cleaned uh military doesn't matter
because Bart didn't read the call
shooting
like smoke signals or something yeah
yeah
we're gonna we're gonna walk you in what
about you Ryan I'm Ryan the funny thing
is that I really wanted to very badly
yeah but uh three things that ruined it
one was at three two people died
my recruiter died
lost my paperwork he got circumcised
during boot camp time
I wanted to join but then um what
happened is for firstly I was more
concerned about being rebellious against
my parents and that's what they wanted
me to do so I didn't want to do they
wanted you to go to the military yeah my
dad really wanted me to join the Marines
you would always like tell me that as an
infantry because in our religion
everyone became a medic interesting yeah
because it's more of a caretaker yeah
because they were like if there's ever a
draft or if there's any type of
um you know military work that you have
to sign up for they're like passive go
into go into medic don't be don't don't
don't
yeah but that means you're that that's
like being the radio operator guy dude
you're on the front [__] lines I
guess it's better and more
yeah sin free they didn't really care
about that they were just that's not
rich don't pick up a gun my dad would
just like always remind me about that
like as I was growing up but then once I
got to my rebellious stage I just didn't
want to do anything they wanted me to do
so then like even though I wanted to
join I didn't want to because it
Rebellion took precedence so I was like
I'm doing that and then the second thing
was uh there was a recruiter who came to
the high school uh he had went he
graduated from my high school and he
came back to talk to the kids about it
and he just did such a bad job he just
like he just seemed like a boring person
first of all so then like once you don't
win as a as a Charisma person then you
just It's A Hard Sell yeah and then he
started saying like what it was like for
him in the Marines and he's like yeah I
did a lot of training what we do is we
uh we go into the water and then we we
test and we uh you have specific amount
of seconds to inflict pain on your
partner as you're underwater and he just
kept saying that and we were like that
doesn't sound fun man he's like the
food's pretty [__]
oh well sometimes the chicken's okay he
was just so boring and he just kept
saying this like water training thing
over and over and we're just like dude
that sucks and then like nobody was into
it what a shitty yeah he really that was
a big part of it and then the third part
was that somehow I don't know how this
happened but I got it in my head that
if you did poorly academically then you
would never make it in the military oh
well you couldn't just join and get like
a rank
or like um be um an officer because like
the way that our school and the teachers
would make you feel about your grades is
that like that affected everything in
your life so then like we all thought
and it wasn't just me but we were like
oh dude like I didn't I gotta see in in
Geometry I'm probably gonna suck at the
military like we just equated like your
uh academic proficiency with how good
you would be at anything so we were like
oh dude I'll die the first day
I remember telling my dad that my dad
was like why don't you just go and I'm
like dude I was like I'll probably be
killed but my first day there my dad's
like no you're not you're not even gonna
die you're not gonna use geometry over
there he was trying to like tell me all
those things that they're not connected
I think that's the that's the fire of
like your parents and your family and
your church and your friends and
everybody telling you your whole life
that like hey whatever happens to you in
school with your grades is gonna affect
your whole life so then I just thought
they were linked that's like the biggest
lie that [__] sucks it's the biggest
lie yeah and it discourages everything
so I was like why did I think that why
did I go to school what made you doing
Bert
um I feel like like the the way like
Ryan worded it almost feels like
um majority of people want to join and
then so what was the reason why you did
it why you didn't why you did it but I
felt like the consensus was the other
way like most people went to college
and then so for me
um I messed up so much in like my
academic career that I was like I
definitely don't have the tools to do
well in college because I got kicked out
like four schools and all I spent five
years in high school you know so I'm
like
studying and reading and stuff it's
definitely not for me
um and then I also I think like my dad
has always held like the military in a
high regard like he not in a way of like
like a doctor but he always felt like um
the way he said it was like this is like
how like a Rite of Passage to like like
uh have discipline and and kind of be
your own man type of deal and then so I
was like that started like simmering in
my brain I think like junior year when I
started to realize like everyone's
trying to take SATs and stuff people are
getting their scores back like applying
to college and already kind of skipped
that whole process and I'm like I'm not
really doing any of that stuff
and I was like maybe I'll go talk to
some recruiters and
um I went to like the Army recruiter
didn't really Vibe with them that much
went to the Navy recruiter didn't really
Vibe with him that much and then I went
to the Marine Recruiting Office in
Montebello I was actually set on joining
the Army but then I was like these two
guys are kind of whack they kind of felt
like used car salesman like all slimy
and [__] like hey you wanna you wanna
see the world or whatever I'm like don't
talk to him like you jump out of
helicopters do the world yeah I don't
know that's weird and I go to the the
Marine office I'm like hello anybody in
here
and then this guy like crawls up from
underneath the desk you're like oh
you're here to join the Marines all
right dude this is my place
and that's not a used car salesman I'm
like this [__] don't give a [__]
yeah he reminds me of me and then I try
to talk to him but he just seems so
[__] wow that's funny because that's
the hardest branch in the military by
far yeah but he didn't he just he's like
the most undisciplined one but I liked
it because he just didn't like give a
[__] everyone else was like
that you're like like I I think this guy
like takes his job for way more than
what it is like all you're trying to do
is sign up kids that's a real job right
and then this guy like he looks like
this guy's a nerd yeah hero is trying to
save the future of this country that's
kind of tight yeah and this guy gets up
he doesn't give a [__] and then he
almost
Vibe of like okay wrap it up because I
gotta go coach wrestling soon can I come
back tomorrow I got more questions all
right so I was like that's a Salesman
right there yeah it almost like hurry up
lost going in he's kicking but in your
in your experience you played hard to
get in your experience being in the
Marines right and then like do you know
everyone's past story and like why they
joined and like what type of people
joined oh yeah all different it's crazy
like when you the minute you hit boot
camp at least in the Marine Corps
uh west of the Mississippi they all go
to MCRD San Diego in the Camp Pendleton
everyone else goes to Paris Island so I
only meet people that are from like
Texas Oklahoma whatever everyone that's
uh west of the Mississippi and there's
people where they come from military
towns it's like that's like being a
doctor in their town There's broken
families broken homes there's ones where
uh the whole family is like military and
they're just trying to carry on the
tradition there's people that are like I
literally don't know what to do like
there's people that you see like when
you first join in the platoon it was
like 90 people and then within the first
week or two it goes down to 70. what do
you mean they get weeded out yeah they
just get weeded out of them not in boot
camp and boot camp immediately because
sometimes people that are just like oh
[__] I signed up for the wrong [__] you
could leave like that
or you get medically discharged or like
people's bones break there's like or
people recruiters not doing a good job
like the recruiter is supposed to set
you up so like the minute you sign up
and until you finish your senior in high
school you're supposed to set up all
these events that you can go exercise
and train so like I think like I don't
know what the bare minimum pull-ups is
but they're supposed to get you to do
the bare minimum Pull-Ups so that when
you come into boot camp oh I didn't know
that yeah you don't die then there's
people so the first day that you go in
there is a physical fitness test and
then there's like a ton of people that
just died and you're like oh [__] you're
a recruiter did not do their job
preparing you and then so like a bunch
of people get weeded out and then you
start connecting and then yeah there's
people from all walks of life there's
guys that are like 30. there's guys that
are like 17 super young
um super like super jocks that were like
cut it with D1 and high school or
college like you just the whole the
whole gamut yeah if there's a draft
would you guys Dodge it absolutely
today absolutely but like what's the TR
what's the real war what's the fight and
what would we do at our age it's like if
aliens came down every [__] Nation
had to pull together it's like I don't
know about dodging it's like yeah let's
go yeah let's [__] fight that I'd
also kind of think they're tight so I'd
have it'd be a tough time yeah it'd be a
tough one as long as we're in Bart's
platoon yeah yeah if we could be
together that'd be tight if aliens were
trying to war on us though I'd be like
that's [__] up yeah don't try to war
on us don't try to walk I really like
the idea of like if that recruiter that
talked to you could just read you as a
person so well it sees you walking up
he's like
he's like an expert person reader yeah
he's like oh oh those guys they look
like they already want to join
no what's up play art again hard to get
mode
I heard that I heard that rumor or
whatever or maybe it's not a rumor maybe
it's true that um you can only be Air
Force pilot if you had like 20 20 vision
and at that time I had I was gonna I
think you need to be I think we need to
be better yeah I was in the four eyes
club and I had glasses so it just
shattered my dream so I genuinely was
like I'll never there were a lot of
rumors like that oh yeah another reason
but that's a real rumor though that's
real though that's real you have to have
better than 2020 let's be 2010 2015. but
at the time they didn't come out with
this [__] called Lasik so I just my
green my dreams were crushed yeah it was
asthma thing too like if you have asthma
you can't do it uh yeah I mean but
everyone lies on [__] like the recruiter
will almost help you lie like I remember
like he's like oh did you like like ever
smoke any weed or doing your drugs and I
was like what am I supposed to say
you're like I would just say like you
didn't touch the other stuff so don't
say I did Ecstasy but I never even heard
of that and I'm like okay I never did
ecstasy and I'm like what about weed I'm
like uh I did but he goes oh you're
probably experimented right I was like
yeah I just experimented maybe like 40
55 times
75 times just say like once or twice you
don't try to fill up the form like
there's no field for the amount that I
did they'll help you out you know that's
because a lot of these guys like I
didn't do them I sold them is that like
a lot of them they know they're trying
to help this guy get to a better life
right so they're almost like don't rat
yourself out like here's your chances
you know you know recruitment's at like
an all-time low right now right now yeah
full-time month yeah but it's not just
the states it's happening to other
countries too yeah yeah
which uh interracial marriages are most
prominent
Zimbabwe wins
foreign